Une visite officielle qui a
tout l'air de retrouvailles
entre de vieux amis.
C'est la première visite d'Étt
de Joe Biden depuis qu'il est
président et la Maison-Blanche a
mis le paquet pour le président
français.
Le tapis rouge est déroulé,
21 coups de canon et
la marseillaise a résonné
en plein coeur de Washington.
♪ ♪ ♪
Les deux dirigeantseueulent
afficher un front uni,
une alliance presque
indéfectible, selon Joe Biden.
"La France est notre plus
vieille alliée", dit-il.
EMMANUEL MACRON,
président de la France
- Face au retour de la guerre
sur le sol européen, suite
à l'agression russe contre
l'Ukraine et face aux crises
multiples qui frappent
nos nations et nos sociétés,
il nous faut savoir
redevenir frères d'armes.
- Une alliance qui avait plutôt
mal commencé. Il y a un an,la Fé
son ambassadeur de Washington
après l'annulation par
l'Australie d'un gros contrat
d'achat de sous-marins français
au profit des Américains.
Autre tension commerciale,
Paris déplore le protectionnisme
américain au détriment des
entreprises européennes.
- En particulier l'"Inflation
Rectction Act" ou le "Cheap
Act" sont des choix qui vont
fragmenter l'Occident.
- Aujourd'hui, le ton étaitplus.
- Et donc, la France n'est pas
venue ici demander en quelque
sorte pour son économi
telle ou telle exception.
On veut réussir ensemble,
pas l'un contre l'autre.
- Ensemble aussi sur la question
ukrainienne.
Aujourd'hui, les deux leaders
sont unis contre la Russie.
"Poinine est en train
d'infliger un terrible carnage
à la population civile
en Ukraine", dit-il.
"Je suis prêt à lui parler,dite
pour arrêter la guerre".
Quant à Emmanuel Macron,
depuis le début du conflit,
il a toujours maintenu
une communication avec
Vladimir Poutine.
- Et donc, en particulier,
j'aurai une discussion sur
la questiodede la sûreté et
de la sécurité des centrales
nucléaires dans les zones
contestées, en particulier
celle de Zaporijia.
- Les deux pays s'engagent
donc à soutenir l'Ukraine
aussi longtemps qu'il le faudra.
Washington a l'inteioion de
bien ménager son allié européen.
400 personnes ont été conviées
pour le dîner d'État, dont
le cinéae e français Claude
Lelouch. Et Emmanuel Macron
s'envolera pour la Nouvelle-
Orléans demain, vendredi.
La première visite d'un
président français depuis 1976.
Ici Azeb Wolde-Giorghis,
Radio-Canada, Washingto